comparison is a formula that's why  social media is so dangerous comparison  is a formula for misery and what we do  in our life is we compare ourselves to  the best day and the best picture on  social media that we see of somebody  else we compare ourselves at different  times in our lives too you know even if  you're in a relationship comparing your  relationship in its fifth year to its  fifth week isn't fair to that  relationship there's different stages in  our life so comparison is a pathway  there's pathways to happiness and  there's pathways that lead us to  unhappiness one of those for sure is  comparison and it's an ego thing often  times with us we're always trying to  one-up things in our life it's a matter  i think really of being more present in  the moment in your life and saying i  deserve to be happy right now